it's physically and emotionally
exhausting
sleep is brief no one has stopped for
days but the determination of these
rescue teams both Turkish and
international many of them are
volunteers is unbreakable we have been
working with with this minor people from
turkey and then they call us to confirm
with our dog and other coffee and has
not been mistaken ever they have
miraculously seven days on identified
life and are working to reach what's
believed to be a mother and her three
week old baby
but they have seen too much death here
and a really sad thing we have been
talking about this we will call it when
we found people there are children are
always in the bed and parties are trying
to reach the children they are coming to
the to the their bedroom
the task of the rescue and Recovery
workers is
devastation
we'll wear it and
told me he said it's the scope of the
damage across the southeast that makes
what is already an incredibly difficult
task even more challenging
Gian gear is a local volunteer he's been
working with firefighters for Azerbaijan
even though we remove a dead body and we
give the corpse to the family they still
hug us and thank us that they got the
body back to pray over and bury
grateful even to be handed you're dead
this is the reality of this unimaginable
tragedy
one rescue worker told us
even if all the countries in the world
send teams to help
it would never be enough
Stephanie Decker Al Jazeera karaman
marash South Eastern Turkey